foreign
just an ordinary American guy who worked
as a Pepsi truck driver delivering
product to shelves and then he climbed
the ladder and got stripped off the
Middle East
started working hard to make a name for
himself and he got taken away from us in
2008 and I think it's been I think it's
been enough time I think I think the
Biden Administration in the state
department should should look at our
case
and treat it with a little more respect
because we haven't even been given any
of that my Dad should be out
[Music]
the story behind my dad is that he's an
American citizen worked in Texas most of
his life early on long before I was born
worked for Pepsi and eventually he moved
to the Middle East with Pepsi
and from Pepsi he moved into Banking and
from banking into real estate and then
in 2008
is when everything unfolded
my dad submitted his resignation
went into a auditing meeting and never
came home that was in March of 2008 I
was 14 years old
and I just turned 30 last week he took
this little real estate company that he
ended up working for and made it what it
became and built so much of what Dubai
is known for and then they just tore him
down I think he was sentenced to 25
years
after the 25 years
if he doesn't pay what they're saying he
took he gets another 25 years tacked on
as a non-payment sentence so by then my
my dad's about to be he's 58 years old
he'll be 60 in two years by then my dad
will be close to 90. and they've changed
the sum that they accuse him of stealing
embezzling whatever the word is they've
changed it so many times it makes no
sense and then if the big four KPMG pw's
Deloitte PWC I think that's what they're
called and there's one more they never
found any errors or margins no
write-offs no write Downs in any of the
books and I if so it's either a case
that they all lied to cover for my dad
for some unknown reason or there there
was nothing taken Zach shuffles around
um we never got let outside because it
was during Kobe locked down so we spent
well I spent months and months never
leaving us leaving the small cells Zach
was just across the corridor from me I
could see him through the bars he was in
his little area with 60 guys I was in my
over 60 guys and he was his door was a
few feet away from mine the lights are
never turned off it's freezing cold all
of the time and we he had no facilities
to wash or clean anything I had the same
dirty old blanket for nine well almost
10 months slept on the same dirty old
rubber mattress never once washed my
blanket or my mattress in those 10
months so Zach's been there 15 years no
wonder he's got rotting sores all over
his body I did have conversations with
Zach and there's times when you can see
a glimmer of light in his eyes and he
talks about his story
um most of what I've discovered is some
research from going through the papers
when I got out I'm 59 years of age I
have never in my life witnessed such
Injustice
earlier this year is when his health
really took a dive but it's been
progressively happening and he's been in
the hospital for the last two months
he's undergone two abdominal surgeries
in that time frame and he's just rotting
away in an emirati Hospital
instead of an American Hospital getting
God knows what kind of treatment
and nobody seems to care he is a sick
man we don't know how long he's going to
live he's got lots of ailments I mean
even Rami did not mention everything
this is beside the depression that he
has you know
lost the will to live he is rotting I
mean if you can imagine a man is dying
because he's Rotting ulcerated Flesh is
having to be cut away from his body so
they're cutting bits of zackawaii and
he's dying trying to fight the
infections in the last few months let's
just say I've been
hanging on a little bit of Hope thinking
that maybe by some miracle the state
department would do the right thing and
get my dad out we wrote a number of
Mercy letters and we they were
humbly asking for the UAE to return and
not even mentioning that he's innocent
he shouldn't be there simply asking for
him to be returned on medical grounds I
only said that he can die at home with
his family ultimate one out of this
Mercy somebody move please pick up the
phone let this guy fly to the medical
center in Houston close to his family
where he can have you know whatever it
is left of his of his life
I wrote I wrote a
a a a plea for Mercy just pretty much
telling the the leader of the UAE just
let my dad out if you find it in your
heart he's sick and dying he's and then
the state department comes back and says
you should take this part out and you
should take this part out so we did that
we deleted everything and then finally
two weeks later we sent them this very
dumbed down version of a mercy letter
and then a day or two later Brittany
Greiner gets out I see the headlines the
United Arab Emirates everybody helped
and there's my dad still sitting in the
hospital
it made me Furious that they didn't even
think to mention this sick man's name
they completely abandoned us so no I
don't have faith that the state
department will do anything
I I think they completely pushed us to
the side
I don't maybe we're not newsworthy
enough for them you know we're not
famous we're just an ordinary family and
they just left us
um but to have the letters pushed back
and sat on for days and weeks
while the UAE was obviously helping
America negotiate Britney's Grinders
released
it's clearly obvious that the the state
department did not want to antagonize
the UAE during this diplomatic process
um by
allowing you an American citizen or an
American Family to criticize jail
conditions in Dubai don't tell us we
wait until we hear from them pick up the
phone talk to them I mean you've been
talking to them about Brittany Greiner
we're very happy for her we're not just
jealous you know we're we're here to say
take an active role in releasing a sick
man a sick American man who has been
thrown in jail for the last 15 years I
feel like my dad's situation was an
inconvenience to the US
and when they were working with the
United Arab Emirates and Russia to
negotiate breiner's Greiner Bernie
greiner's release
I feel like maybe they thought hey let's
let's not mention Zach Shaheen
while we're working to get her out
because
it might it might not go right with them
Zack's the elephant in the room he's the
guy no one wants to talk about despite I
mean everybody knows about Zach I mean I
was in the jail with him Zach has got
more mental health issues than anyone
I've ever come across the man is a
broken wreck
he lost hope a long time my dad lost
hope years ago and I don't think he
thinks anybody's going to get him out so
I will
I'm going to keep fighting until he gets
out and if I fail then so be it but I'll
never let this go and I think my dad
deserves
a chance at life
went in he went in at 43 years of age
he's 58 now
a shell of what he used to be I I don't
even recognize the man I hear on the
phone his wife is almost in Jade with
him my sister you know she's not with us
now because she's a broken woman she
never stopped crying for the last 15
years so I look at my mom and she's just
Hollow my dad was like her right hand
that just empowered her and made her
feel whole and everything and now 15
years without him and then me
I don't know I try to put on a front and
act like strong for my family and for my
dad
but
I feel like I lost a part of myself when
he went in there so we're all we're all
broken
not much else to say on that